oh yeah
Seville the cradle of flamenco here in
southern Spain the dance has a long
tradition which new and unusual about it
here is the venue where it's being
performed a kind of giant sunshade it's
become the attraction in Seville it's
called the metropol parasol and the city
authorities hope it will draw even more
international tourists it was designed
by architect yogamaya H from Berlin
yogamaya H is regarded as something of a
trendsetter on the international
architecture scene along with Mota
ramires Iglesias and Andre Santa he drew
up plans to be juvenile rundown Plaza in
Seville the idea was to combine modern
architecture with sustainable living
nakada Scott Vijaya hot cittàgazze amet
nowadays sustainability is talked about
in very limited terms concentrating
mainly on ecological aspects but the
metropol parasol project also emphasizes
other aspects such as cultural relevance
a project should also reflect a city's
overall creative approach and its own
potential for innovation non stop being
a doctor and slow
trees as providers of shade served as
models with a blueprint shade plays an
important role in seville where summers
are hot and not only the forms are
innovative the materials used are new to
us th Idol when the decision was finally
made to build this great sculptural
structure out of wood everyone involved
was very enthusiastic one reason was
that the wood comes from certified
timber in other words from sustainable
forestry so it's a material that grows
back an ecological material another
reason was the wood does not heat up
like metal for example and that new
strong timber based materials allow us
to create free forms in a cost-efficient
way that's a stone a structure like this
had never been built before so there
were many unknowns to contend with more
than 3,000 elements from veneered
plywood had to be combined in a complex
three-dimensional structure for the
architects it was groundbreaking work
mata ramirez Iglesias oversaw the
building work on the site it was the
Spaniards first major project respecting
mostly based our planning on a
programmable surface like a pixel matrix
pixels are points of intersection that
belonged to a new language a new medium
of communication estas pixel s within
these pixels can pop up combine and
unite and destroy different shapes the
pixels are components of the matrix and
grow from the ground up even the
supporting sections are made of finds
Bruce elements a layer of polyurethane
renders the wood weather resistant but
to give it the required structural
stability a new technique had to be
developed yeah Tony honest so on
elementals comparison coladas the
joining elements such as the threaded
bolts were also treated with adhesive
possibly gracias el sistema a heating
process made the adhesive extra strong
there this technique using extra heat
resistant adhesive makes the structure
capable withstanding the very high
summer temperatures and Seville of up to
50 degrees Celsius support our estas
garage
the wooden superstructure covers some
3,000 square meters and plays host to
all kinds of cultural events
today's program promises free flamenco
lessons for all comers riad 5,000
kilometers to the southeast the capital
of Saudi Arabia is also the country's
economic and cultural hub the oil boom
has transformed this once remote desert
oasis into a rapidly growing metropolis
there are construction sites dotted all
over the city and it is Western
architects who have given Riyadh its
modern face now a new landmark is being
built in the city center the King Fahad
national libraries to become Riyadh's
cultural center piece it's being built
by a team of architects from the German
city of Dortmund ones of action of our
reaction to the city planning
environment here was to build something
that is both exciting and relaxing
something that stands out by being able
to create a breathing space a space for
reflection within the fabric of the city
that's all you can come
Thomas looking has been involved in
building the library for more than 10
years now he spent several of these
years living in Riyadh until recently
energy efficient construction methods
were practically unheard of in Saudi
Arabia that could change with the
construction of the new National Library
the hot desert climate can make daily
life in the region difficult so it's all
the more important that buildings have a
pleasant indoor temperature to make this
possible the National Library received a
special form of cladding levadiakos vida
de casado if you don't want a mirrored
facade you have to figure out a
different kind of protection from the
Sun what we did was go back to
traditional forms of construction such
as tents membranes textiles curtain wall
facings and so on we developed a
separate sunshield facade which we hung
over the glass facade it's a bit like a
feather cloak or a bird puffing up its
feathers the Sun that beats down from
above is blocked off completely but when
you're inside you can look down and
you've got a clear view of outside
dynasty facade a contract offer
that way the architects were able to
avoid high costs for air conditioning
inside the building a displacement
ventilation system saves more money
cooled air is fed in slowly at floor
level only saving the necessity to cool
the entire volume of the huge reading
hall behind frosted panes a separate
library is being built on the first
floor men are usually not allowed in
here
presenting their own beauty we're in the
women's library now it's a separate area
for women and children it's also only
about a quarter of the size of the men's
library of course this was an issue for
us one which we had to address oh we
also had to obscure the women's area
from the men's view so we developed a
modern ornament for the windowpanes
portraying falling leaves it's part of a
reference to the theme of Arcadian
landscapes the architects had to get
used to their new working conditions and
the general environment half the
population of Saudi Arabia lives behind
a veil women are not allowed to drive
cars travel work or marry without the
consent of their male Guardians
sorry Arabia is the home of Wahhabism a
particularly strict form of Islam
Oh
to this day this square is used for
public executions western music and
alcohol are forbidden there's hardly any
tourism the country is only slowly
opening up to the outside world the
kingdom of saudi arabia laid out strict
ground rules for the construction of the
new library insisting on the
preservation of an older building from
the 1980s the idea of preserving
existing buildings runs contrary to the
philosophy behind groundbreaking
spectacular architecture most architects
find the idea of constructing new
buildings while preserving old ones
unattractive ikot gabba founder of gaba
architects in dortmund accepted the
challenge and it was the older building
that inspired his ecological design for
a new one that is a minor heidegger's
concept it's a sustainable concept
because by placing the older building at
the central point and cloaking it with a
new building we were surrounding it like
the smaller parts of a Russian
matryoshka doll giving it total
protection from the climate outside
furthermore to me sustainability means
preserving older buildings hi doll and
that I didn't either bottoms these are
resources which have already been used
and we can't just tear them down and
throw them away we should be using them
again and again Ananda vana a movie
Durbin Watson
China on the other hand is turning
toward new more imposing styles of
architecture like in Dalian in the
northeast of China the city by the
Yellow Sea is a popular destination for
Chinese tourists 6 million people live
in the greater metropolitan area the
city is also one of the country's
biggest commercial hubs but Dalian wants
to shake off its image as an ugly
industrial city and finally attract
international tourists a modern city
quarter is being built at the container
port with the Dalian international
conference center on the new case it's a
futuristic building with an energy
concept that uses wind sea water and
sunlight
Oh
it's being built by the architect wolf
des prix and his team from Austria Prix
is something of a maverick was famous
for his extravagant designs just the
right man to help dalian attract
attention before God while and conquests
and our brief was to build a conference
center it's right then a second more
important room it was added namely to
build an opera house within the
conference center then we knew what our
real task was to build a commercial
conference center with a cultural heart
the Opera House had super saiyan limit
whatever for the Opera House the
architects had to meet certain aesthetic
and acoustic criteria this is the bones
in Vegas to Donna from the past
especially within the pouch tailor the
phone india garden the venue is to be
used not just for opera performances but
also for pop concerts and theater
productions the grand theatre has room
for seventeen hundred spectators
one of the novelties is a flexible stage
wall which can be opened if needed
behind it is an enormous function room
that makes a wide range of uses possible
without additional expense
you
it was back in nineteen sixty eight that
bull d pricks founded the architecture
firm with the exotic name co-op
himmelblau the Austrian has realized his
utopian ideas in many countries dalian
is currently one of his biggest projects
he sees architecture as art and says it
should be at the cutting edge i'lli'll
take it by they have all our buildings
have extremely distinctive forms the
swagga that may alienate the beholder at
first but like all strange things when
you've gotten used to it you see the
advantages of the unusual this me acaba
as I'm so people remember the building
they can describe it that way people
take emotional possession of a building
for link revive it China is building its
future at a breathtaking pace but the
country is facing a dilemma climate
change makes sustainability essential in
both Commerce and construction that's
why cost efficient and ecological
architecture is expressly called for in
the latest five-year plan
the Dalian Conference Center boasts a
complex energy design as it's called in
the trade solar cells on the roof supply
the building with electricity in the
summer the temperatures can reach
tropical heights for the purpose of
cooling the architects decided to take
advantage of its location by the water
today a giant pump system is being
installed it's a big moment for the
architect in charge Wolfgang rushed
Effie I'm here to I largest we have a
unique opportunity here to use the sea
water to cool our building we pump cold
seawater which stays at a constant
temperature all year round into an
underground storage tank from there it
goes to a heat exchange system from
which it is then pumped into the
building's interior by a separate
circuit that circuit feeds concrete
elements floors and walls which
gradually but steadily cool the building
the activia valance langsam de potoski
for the students
light shafts in the ceiling allow as
much sunlight as possible inside
flexible vents also allow wind in
providing for natural ventilation a
perforated aluminum skin offers
protection from the direct Sun but the
architects aim to take ecological
building a step further the real goal is
to eventually construct buildings that
are self-sufficient that supply
themselves with energy so to speak and
if possible generate more energy than
they use themselves they would function
as urban power plants that I think is
the next step that's garbage Eastern
ecstasy
to Berlin where Dortmund based architect
ikot gabba has opened a new office from
here international projects are
coordinated he Thomas looking and other
colleagues are preparing for their next
trip to Riyadh where they're building a
museum on the topic of the environment
in nature since the architecture firm
won the competition for the National
Library it has secured more contracts in
Saudi Arabia Akkad gabba had to do a lot
of persuading to get his clients to buy
into energy efficient architecture
sacamos me tension na hai desh kite is
Saudi Arabian sustainability is a bit of
a problem in Saudi Arabia people are
skeptical energy is dirt cheap and
people don't think sustainability is
necessary here no need for natural
ventilation when you've got air
conditioning that costs next to nothing
but when you spend some time here you
realize that it can't last forever that
the time will come when the oil is used
up under this side Nakamura Gifford
Saudi Arabia has yet to enact binding
regulations on insulation or ecological
architecture but the Saudis two will
have to rethink their approach in the
future the Prince Salman science Oasis
built by garba architects wants to make
its own contribution to that process the
museum is aimed at raising awareness of
environmental issues among children
young people and their families the
museum will feature various interactive
exhibits focusing on topics such as
Earth water life technology and space
for example visitors can board a
spaceship or dive beneath the surface of
the water the concept for the
interactive displays was drawn up by the
berlin-based firm to yacht it aims to
teach visitors about energy-saving
technologies in a fun way although they
are a serious and important aspect of
architecture
this is in javis all this is a solar
updraft tower The Sun heats up air which
rises in the tower and powers a turbine
that generates electricity this will be
demonstrated very nicely in the main
hall visitors can walk into the tower
look up and see the turbine revolving
that way the exhibit is actually part of
the architecture and a landmark feature
of the science oasis for Jesus Sciences
the architect seemed to draw attention
to the topic of landscapes the building
is on the fringe of a Wadi whatís are
typical features of the local landscape
they're dried-out riverbeds that
sometimes fill up with rainwater in the
winter the biggest one is the wadi honey
farm which runs around Riyadh the slant
FTL amend the landscape aspect of the
wadi hanifa became a focal point of the
architecture of the science center
because it runs right up to the main
entrance of our building and gradually
Rises step by step from the open gates
we incorporated this step-by-step effect
into our plans so that we could create a
connection between the landscape of the
wadi and the architecture of the science
center so she didn't tema his body's
havin owns under a particular science
centers but progress on the building is
slow
and
most of the laborers come from
Bangladesh or Pakistan scorching heat
and strict prayer times put a stop to
work on the site several times a day
nobody can say exactly when the museum
will be ready to open
back to seville the medieval city is one
of Europe's most fascinating cultural
destinations and now it's got another
magnet for tourists
the metropol parasol is located in the
middle of the old town on the plaza de
la Encarnacion the plaza has a rich and
varied history it was once the site of a
medieval monastery which was later
turned into a market hall when that was
demolished the plaza was left to
languish as a car park madam red pebble
footing the competition for redesigning
the plaza de la Encarnacion in Seville
was aimed at creating a vibrant urban
setting for the 21st century but it's
also supposed to function as a window on
the city's history with its Roman ruins
and give it back its old function as a
market hall sent home hooks of a bundle
these ruins from the Roman era were
found during excavation work for the new
project they were preserved and
incorporated into the design and now
function as an antiquarian in the
basement of the building
the district residents are now served by
a new weekly market on the ground floor
of the Metropole para saw
and on the roof overlooking the square
is a boardwalk offering spectacular
views of the city skyline
as a construction project the oversized
parasol was as controversial as they
come there was no shortage of criticism
during the building phase the architects
were accused of aesthetic insensitivity
and a lack of respect for savills
cultural treasures they'll kill a scary
because I can't appear in other than I
think the criticism was perfectly normal
we've built something very unusual in
the center of the historical town in
Seville in episode our people need time
to digest it and accept this building
for themselves it's an orchestral Fionna
meanwhile the mushrooms as the locals
call them have put down roots
they've become a fixture of the city's
cultural life
even savills philharmonic orchestra has
done the honors here and the concert
evening was well attended Mason so give
me the way worn a thong forgive it it's
a great feeling to see people using and
enjoying this Plaza they liked what we
were trying to achieve with this open
space it's like an open-air cathedral
for the people of Seville
rithi in seville riyadh or dalian
cultural venues are special places
throughout the world if there is success
they can become icons themselves leaving
their marks on cities for decades that
gives architects a special
responsibility to create great beautiful
functional and ecological buildings